while the countdown is on the national
teacher of the year is going to be
revealed tomorrow
while 56 teachers were in the running it
has now been narrowed down to four as
sally jeremiah reports
it included an educator from the silver
state
julianna is one of three other finalists
across the country she teaches grades
pre-k to fifth
here at kermit booker elementary school
and is the first latina to be a finalist
for teacher of the year since at least
1992
in nevada not only is she an educator
she is also an
advocate juliana urdubay has a bachelor
of arts in bilingual elementary
education and a master's from the
university of arizona
urdu bay is also a national board
certified teacher
for both exceptional needs students and
young adults
i'm obviously very touched and i'm
grateful
um you know this is the year
that we have to represent teachers and
do it with love and
with a smile and so i promise to do that
to the best of my abilities
and to really encourage all teachers
to reflect deeply about their practice
urdu bay students know her as miss earth
since she strives to beautify the school
and unify them through the use of
gardens and murals
sweet honest
and a very good teacher it is exciting
it is just like i think it's a privilege
to be a part of it be
have my kids be in this school i'm so
happy for her
the 2021 national teacher of the year
will spend the next year serving as an
ambassador for
education and an advocate for all
teachers and students
as for the winner it will officially be
announced this thursday
8 news now wishes her all the luck
reporting sally jaramillo
8 news now i want to wish your congrats
too we featured her juliana in what's
cool at school about four years ago what
a talented educator
as for the three other finalists they're
from a middle school teacher from salt
lake city
a high school teacher from north
carolina and an elementary school
teacher from d.c
you know who we're going for we've
teamed up with cbs to bring you the
announcement
during good day tomorrow at 6 a.m good
luck juliana